you were the one who told me what cat
meant yeah yeah [__] yeah what's it mean
Geezer over here uh it means um Giza
Giza is a good word depending where
you're at bro yeah I like Geezer uh cap
means
I mean
you'll stop the cat man it means uh it
means that's fake that's a lie yeah
that's cat but I can't remember why the
way it was I heard it explained is
it and this is like coming from a New
Yorker he was explaining that
if you have your cap low you're being
kind of sheisty so you might like you
might be disguising your gaze so you may
say something but you're hiding your
eyes so if you say it's no cap yeah
you're lifting your cap to you know
you're demonstrating your eyeballs to be
vulnerable as and I'm telling the truth
right got it no cap yeah no cap
you're a [__] handsome man
thank you yeah wow I I feel like [__]
because I've eaten pizza for dinner the
last three nights why uh just because
hungry hungry boy yeah I was hungry
I was craving cheese yeah I was eating
dominoes
yeah what's the matter with that you
don't like dominoes there's just way
better options
in Los Angeles yes where yeah anywhere I
guess there's like local places oh bro
bootleg Pizza in Mar Vista is back shout
out bootleg Pizza Man bootleg Pizza I
I'm partial to a place called Hail
Mary's in Atwater Village but honestly
yeah but the the Domino I was gonna say
McDonald's Domino's Pizza too I'm
surprised they don't yeah at this point
so so this is this a new pie every night
or you ordered one pie and you just been
working it down uh I I had one I
actually okay so I had one pie on
Saturday I saved half of it and then I
went over to my mom's place uh yesterday
and I said we should order Domino's and
she's like okay and then um I still have
the leftover that I'm gonna eat tonight
yeah so it'll be four in a row no three
three so Saturday Sunday and then today
okay got it yeah nice man yeah
I got a side of marinara to dip it in
are you stoked uh yeah I am and I also I
bought two two Donuts this morning binge
bro and I I saved one donut I was like
you know I really want this other
[__] donut right now and I thought
you know show some self-control yeah
save it for dessert yeah nah you're on a
tender right now man yeah but because I
I I I have missed the gym for a few days
so I'm like when that happens I go full
bore and now I'm [__] out I do [__] out
but now I'm gonna go back and um
return to just eating plain
Pizza plain pizza no cheese no cheese no
sauce just um uh left beef yeah do you
remember that no you never saw the the
no nothing left beef Pizza can you just
Google left beef please left beef Pizza
it's been so long since I've seen I want
to like touch you yeah all right you can
do that look at this so someone on
someone on the uh McDonald's
[Laughter]
Ronnie McD you're in my mind baby
someone ordered a nun pizza left beef
never seen this have
okay yeah and I remember someone turned
it into a necklace
um because they sold it on rabbit walked
all over that thing it does
known pizza left beef uh yeah that's
great that's brilliant it actually kind
of looks good yeah it kind of like just
the the bread itself yeah from here I
can't tell if that's like pizza or
um like an apple pie with chocolate bits
on top oh yeah you know what I realized
you get high enough most things look
like food
yeah check this out uh go to YouTube
search
cowhove treatment oh yeah we love
cowhove trimming
now hold on hold on no no no just wait
yeah just click any one of these it's
kind of like coconut that's all I was
about to say get deep enough in this
video it's gonna look like coconut if
you just skipped like five minutes like
coconut like if you just if you just
zoned it that looks like you're cutting
into some Manchego yeah that does yeah
you're right you're high enough
absolutely right just and if you just
you know you cropped out all the
disgusting around it you'd be like what
pasta is this I mean surprise cow the
cow looks a little like food too so what
are these cows constantly [__]
stepping on that they're getting these
infections in their in their Hooves uh I
think just you know all the don't cows
just like stand there and [__] on
themselves no kidding I mean if you just
stood and shat and pissed on your feet
all day I'm sure at some point you're
gonna get an abscess yeah you ever had
an abscess no have you uh no no we
should get one get an abscess shared
yeah that's that's the one thing with
like the pimple popping [__] that I
can't mess with is when they do full-on
abscess drainings just give me straight
blackheads man come on if it's 11 p.m
and I'm I'm laying there in bed just
give me the just give me the blackheads
please yeah it's pretty satisfying to
watch just watching that [__] tube
crawl out of a head
oh Jesus yeah I hate having this mole on
my the left side of my nose because I I
keep forgetting that all right don't
keep forgetting but I feel like people
who don't know me are like Jesus Christ
that's what I think every time I see you
that's all so I'm glad I'm sitting on
this side so yeah it sucks I keep
looking over and I'm like I'm showing my
vulnerable side to the to the audience
yeah you should definitely put your hand
over your face yeah well also I mean
I've I've shown so many more vulnerable
things to these people I don't think a
little nose mole's gone really dude I
commit I always commend your
vulnerability I think it makes you one
of the funniest guys on Earth
Earth's a big place it is
it makes you hysterical thank you yeah
thank you I think a lot of Us wish we
were more like you you just always go
for the ride I mean I do and I don't I
like I I'm definitely a very
cautious person you'd say so
yeah for I don't know I honestly don't
know I think your definition of cautious
is just different yeah I got into it I
didn't get into trouble but I I
um I'm gonna say I gotta do a uber I
shouldn't have or something no no I just
uh Cody and I when I filled in for you
yeah last time we were we were talking
all about relationships yeah and all
about
um
well I guess just was that it were we
just talking about relationships for a
good amount of time yeah yeah and what
else was that it yeah you're being
vulnerable with each other oh yeah it
was real sweet so if you you know yeah
you want to get vulnerable yeah dude
always what else is there I'm down to
get vulnerable with my guys oh oh by the
way sorry
I have to plug
I gotta plug trillion in your mind put
me in the eyes as you do this plug I
gotta plug Julian your mindset okay when
we reach 70 000 YouTube subscribers
we're gonna
um [__] each other no
Zach's gonna kill me because he
literally told me what to say Andy
texted me no don't tell them don't tell
them no no no you can figure it out okay
seventy thousand subscribers we're gonna
God damn it I can't remember
now we're never dude okay Zach just yell
it oh Christ on the cross uh sorry you
don't believe in him no I don't uh oh oh
we're gonna at seventy thousand
subscribers on trillionaire mindset
we're gonna do a we're gonna release a
uh bonus episode like that's normally
why is that [__] funny man you kind
of made it down you gotta Build It Up
that's it okay you killed each other and
then at 70 000 ooh an extra hour of
content you better be [__] each other
hey hey and then at 85 000 subscribers
you're gonna do [__] orgy we're gonna
do our we're gonna do our two hour live
stream because people just want two
hours yeah they can't get enough yeah
and then at a hundred thousand they're
gonna have sex with all of their fans at
the same time all one hundred thousand
only requirement you have to be horny
that's a very low bar to entry you got
to be hard or wet that's all you got to
be show up we'll be right up and show
out it's going to be sponsored by uh uh
Vaseline yeah
yeah just not the ideal lubricant but
it'll do
I remember jerking off using Vaseline
and thinking was it a slow process well
it just was it was disgusting because
afterward I'd be like God damn I gotta
like no I'm gonna get it there
yeah I guess it was pretty bad
you'd do anything at that age I remember
trying did you ever tried Sriracha yeah
no socks
foreign
did you really fill the Ziploc bag full
of lotion oh my God my mom woke up the
next day she's like I'm gonna be dry as
hell for the rest of the month who took
all of my [__] lotion wait you put
lotion into a bag into a sock oh okay
you need to do that did you no I didn't
yeah that's that's how you knew I was an
engineer no I ravaged my poor little
penis just raw in the sauce put it in a
Brillo pad just it was yeah I was like
why do they always tout this in movies
as being like the thing this is very
uncomfortable yeah no you yeah you fill
it with lotion and then if you want to
go extra crazy this was the first
flashlight this was before fleshlights
were let me guess let me guess was it a
fruit no no
no it's still with the sock in the
Ziploc Evolution what was it
put it between two mattresses
then you can [__]
to hand that hoe
that is impressive that is very smart
yeah see yeah we're we were smart kids
yeah not really though no no not at all
because because
um
uh a mattress
like I contemplated it when I like
eyeballed the mattress I'm like no way
first of all because I didn't have a
dual mattress system it was only in my
parents room
and I'm like that's desecration right
there
but then also the height from like the
bed from the ground to it's it's like
about where we're sitting yeah
to do you have to be like on your knees
well I mean yeah you gotta that's doggy
style dude it is but you can't doggy
style two mattresses you did though you
may not happen no I didn't
oh oh yeah yeah yeah I went very tall
yeah
no that's just gripping for dear life
well what did you
so I just you know I took the sock with
the lotion oh okay that's what my
question was going to be is what did you
put in between the the mattresses yeah
you put the Ziploc bag of lotion inside
the sock yeah you just
go go ham man I did it for about 30
seconds and I'm like this is crazy and
stupid and it was just like shooting
lotion all over my pelvis yeah and I
just I'm like why don't I just [__]
yeah yeah
man thank God we don't have to do that
anymore right yeah right now you just
[__] a thermos